foreign
foreign
foreign
the three Muslims today we're joined
with the man himself
the Sunnah man or the Sun the guy is
damn bro got my name wrong in the first
five seconds
foreign
you know it wasn't actually me bro it
was actually
um a friend of mine who said who made
setup for me and then once he kind of
laid the foundation I just started like
building on it so I blew the lights and
stuff like that man but yeah as I said
that's the perks for being a filmmaker
bro so it's a nice one so and plus you
know when you're editing all day like
you need to have like a den you need
like a man cave you need something that
looks vibey like a nice cozy place you
know what I mean bro so yeah yeah I'll
handle that I have like a six by six
little like office
I made it myself
oh you you could do a lot with that as
well man it's all about what you can do
with your space you know what I mean
like as in that that's the most
important thing the vibe is real bro you
need Ambience you need something nice to
kind of for
me anyway
yeah 100 100 we got brother Zachary
saying Rami
people just pop up with like chats and
stuff yeah so there's a whole comment
section to uh to the side I don't know
if you'll see it but to the side here
and um I like when someone sends out
I'll just pull it up here for us so we
don't get any of the bad ones inshaallah
but you you mentioned your uh filmmaker
right
yes bro yeah yeah so I'm I'm interested
about that because I think filmmaking
especially for Muslims is very powerful
because RF is taking a course I feel
like every time I talk I mention I'm
taking a course related to this topic so
it seems like I'm taking 50 different
courses but um I'm taking a course on
culture and media and they talk a lot
about how films like there was a film
man I a few decades ago I forget when
but a while ago and I actually
revived the the triple K because I don't
want to say the full thing you know the
white group it revived them just based
on the cinematography the Innovations
they made and and the way it was filmed
so media is is powerful so Allah I want
to hear what you have to say about media
and how you got into it and what you
think you can do for Muslims absolutely
but absolutely so firstly
um firstly thank you for for inviting me
on here
um
bring the best distance gathering this
Pro this live stream this video Bears
the righteous roots inshallah so um okay
filmmaking and media in general
basically this is something that I'm
extremely passionate about because when
it comes to uh media this is the voice
of the masses right this is the this is
the the tool and this is the Poetry uh
like the Poetry of the Arabs is like the
media of today the film The filmmaking
of today the rappers the filmmakers the
whole media industry
Muslims I feel have not even utilized it
one percent I feel that we have totally
just said like you know it's like when
the printing press happened and the West
were creating uh books and they were
printing books the Muslims were behind
for over 100 years we just lagged and
lagged and lagged and they went so far
ahead and then we're like okay you know
what let's just let's let's start doing
it now because there was so much fatal
and so many things that were just
holding people back holding people like
you can't do it don't do it and then
like you know we realized that the
innovation of the West it trumped and
and they kind of that's what the
Renaissance happened they were all kind
of like flying now that like as in they
were they were moving forward so we
should take a lesson from history and
that is that when it comes to Media we
have not touched the surface whatsoever
and there's always going to be problems
there's always going to be issues
especially with media especially working
in media how you portray what you
portray what to use vocal only beats Etc
women with hijab there's so many
different nuances there that you know uh
again you know can I guess be
bottlenecks but I feel that it's a tool
that we have to master now and if we
truly Master this not only in this day
and age will we leave a legacy behind
like you have to understand that sorry
what I wouldn't say was not only will it
benefit the people but we will also
leave a legacy behind for those who get
to watch our content for the future as
well and so the way it all started for
me was um
I watched The Avengers The Avengers
movie right and I don't I don't watch
movies but this was in covid and this
was basically in 2020 I watched endgame
and I haven't seen any of the Avengers
movie and I'm looking at and like you
know because like we were in Ramadan my
brother just put it on and like you know
passing time throughout the day and then
it was Eden you know we just sat home
all day and I see Spider-Man I see Hulk
I see Iron Man like whoa what the hell
is this man like this is like the
biggest collection of like superheroes
what's going on and I watched it and I
was like hold on let me watch it from
the start man so then I'm from 2008 Iron
Man I've been just every single Avengers
movie and when I came to the end of it I
was like bro this I don't know what's
happened to me this is like changed me
man I don't know how he's changing me
but I feel emotional as in I'm so drunk
I'm so drawn in as far now from there I
realized that we have to do something
when it comes to media and so that's
when I started my YouTube channel which
was in 2020 and I started making short
films and I'd handle after making about
eight nine short films I then uh made my
first professional film and
alhamdulillah was released in cinemas in
the UK as well so it was uh it was the
first Islamic film in the UK to be shown
in cinemas alhamdulillah so it was it
happened very fast because again in
covid you're just at home you're not
doing anything and because I had the
advantage of like no one going outside
and the lockdown and everything I just
honed it on the skill and just kind of
yeah man just developed it and just kind
of uh used it to my advantage and then
obviously now like now the film has
finished and I'm now just focused on
kind of creating content online and I've
got a few other things in the pipeline
as well but media is something that I
feel that Muslims have to take advantage
of and they have to utilize to the best
of their ability because it is the voice
of the future bro and if we don't
control this space if you don't have our
presence in this space we will get
drowned out and Allah when I look at the
Dua and I look at the the kind of dawa
scene I just see I just feel that what
we need to really do is to drown this
space out and to drown out the noise of
evil of
immorality because that is so loud and
so prominent that we I feel we are fully
asleep on on the biggest thing and that
is Media bro we have to we have to be in
the space bro Allah that's I I truly I'm
as you can tell I'm very passionate
about that bro
what's your uh what's your movie called
my movie is called two sides so uh two
sides of trailers on my YouTube channel
and uh and so sorry bro was that your
movie
yeah I made the movie I've heard about
it of course really okay
so two sides I I I'm I'm the director of
two sides I wrote it
um and alhamdulillah bro it was um yeah
man it was it was emotional but it was
it was good man we had imagine imagine
boy you got you got like you know
thousands like so in our Prem you had
about a thousand people turn up so there
were two uh different screenings of like
500 people each and imagine that the
whole Cinema's packed and like
subhanallah you've got the Quran being
recited in the cinema you've got Allah's
name being mentioned and like and the
the craziest thing was is that in front
of the big Silver Screen like we had a
Java of like two 250 people there bro
and it was Hannah people were looking at
like this is the first time since
Cinemas have been around in the west
that Muslims have actually had the
chance to go in and actually like
dominate this place and just kind of
have Allah there and it was a very proud
moment bro so alhamdulillah man yeah
that was uh that was great man and it
was probably the biggest project I've
ever done do you uh martial do you know
brother uh Gabriel Romani
I was in Dubai with him a few months ago
and we were just you know on a late
night drive and he was telling me you
know what the biggest problem is in the
Dao scene I was like what he was like
there's no one doing proper professional
content and I didn't really take him
seriously back then you know what I mean
because you know me Rami we turned on
the camera bro in our homes you know we
just talked chop it up on the on the
three Muslims but he was saying there's
no one taking like proper like
mirrorless cameras going outside
professional mics lighting and doing
that real type of Netflix Hollywood type
content you know for like the Muslim
equivalent and he he was saying that
that's there's a huge reason when people
opt in for like a lot of the things that
you're saying they choose that because
there's that Cutting Edge technology you
know what I mean once the Muslims they
don't really have that so he was saying
we got to bring that back
I agree with him there are attempts like
like don't get me wrong like one path
network uh you've got Buddha Muhammad as
well who's doing his thing in Canada as
well and like there's there's stuff but
I just feel that the problem is is that
all that stuff is um it's all privatized
and that's why it ends up having really
a private label and people do it for a
business reason they do it for kind of a
an income generating opportunity as well
not not necessarily like kind of like
one path because they've got a big pool
of funds anyway but like what ends up
happening is that it just doesn't go
online it just doesn't get shown to
people and the vision of two sides was
to eventually release it online so we
will stream it for a while inshallah but
then we want to leave it put it online
for the Muslims to see in like
indefinitely kind of thing so I agree
this space is like it's it's bro it's
it's Baron bro and like it's there's no
one here but at the same time it's
fertile land bro like literally if you
enter this space you will get tractions
like very very quickly with two sides we
realize bro there's so much traction so
much traction so many people are like
like they they showed up bro yeah bro we
were shocked when we had a thousand
people turn up to the premiere because
we're nobody like we Criterion Studios
is my is my company uh it's a Film
Production Studio and we are nobodies we
don't have a big celebrity diary that's
going to come promote things we are
known we just come out of nowhere and
alhamdulillah bro we pull an event with
a thousand people going 100 we sold out
in seven different Cinemas that seven
different screenings that we had we sold
out bro and that was the most amazing
thing
so yeah man that was a great journey man
that was very beautiful may Allah bless
you and give you the strength to keep
going Allah I mean I mean I mean
we have brother out of here he's a fan
he's saying I'm actually stumbling upon
some of the guys IG page accidentally uh
but alhamdulillah the contest is so nice
and real that it's hard for me to not
follow your IG keep happening
very beautiful very beautiful
um
so
one I want to ask more about uh media I
don't want to get into the specifics of
you know how you shoot certain things
what kind of shots affect people how
they affect people but I do want to know
are you ever going to make a video like
that for Muslims educating on them on
how to get started with this field
I mean that is one of my aims with my
own YouTube channel as well is that I
feel so so you know when like you come
on YouTube like you feel that like you
have to do things a certain way and then
I'm slowly getting more into my
personality I'm slowly like as in being
uh like sharing the things that I feel
passionate about Etc one of them is
filmmaking inshallah my plan is to help
uh Muslim content creators you know the
only problem with that though is
I find that a lot of Muslim like
videographers and I'm talking but bro
they're all doing stuff that's Haram
like they're all involved in music
they're all involved in like drama
series with women and nudity and stuff
and it's like
even even young Brothers for like
upcoming filmmakers you know they're
doing shoots and they're doing edits and
it's like there's music in there and
there's like you know women being on the
screen and and so really and truly bro
it's like selling headphones isn't it
you know you know when you sell
headphones
um you know that not everyone's gonna
listen to Quran
so so there's a gray area there so
teaching filmmaking I'd love to do it
but I'd love to do it with the caveat
and that is that people make a vow not
to do in the Haram so I've got this
young filmmaker in my area
uh he's 16 17 years old and we were just
fundraising for a camera and Honda we
managed to raise the funds within a day
hundred is great right and I've been
observing him for the past six months
and I said to him if you want my help if
you want me to help you then I don't
want to see you making anything Haram
because he got he got he took my camera
and he started making adverts and in
there they had like music and then I was
like bro what's going on man you're
using my camera and then I took my
camera back off him and like he didn't
like that I know he didn't like it
because because like he was he was using
my camera right and so what ended up
happening is
he said uh like you know bro can I use
the camera on a knob I'm trying to sell
it bro sorry man so so we'll end up so
what ended up happening is I had to make
an excuse and then eventually I sat down
and said to him look the reason why I
took the camera off you was because bro
you started using music you started
doing these things and I did tell you
not to do that but you went ahead of it
as well like he realized that his
mistake
he made repentance and then after that
you know he's been by my side and he's
been creating content he'd be using
vocal only stuff and he's been using
he's not doing anything like that so no
all right you're ready now so then I
raised money for to get my camera
alhamdulillah he's got his camera now so
inshallah like now I'm teaching him but
because I have control over that you
know if you just put a video out
teaching people how to do Transitions
and edits and how to direct things and
write scripts and stuff like that you
don't know who's watching so it might be
if someone watches it and they use that
tool that I've taught them to do
something evil it's something that is
playing with me a little bit and maybe I
need to speak to my teachers and find
out exactly what's the best way to do it
maybe a private course etc for Muslims I
don't know let's see man let's see
inshallah
and that was my first thought because
you know the same way Muslims can can go
to non-muslims and see what they're
doing and you know take it and do good
with it same thing with Muslims they
could take what Muslims are doing and
switch it up and do bad with it which
they have in the past unfortunately but
alhamdulillah may Allah bless you Allah
because it's always good for for young
people to have mentors people they can
look up to so to have someone so local
you know Allah I think that's that's
beautiful so that kind of leads me to my
next question which is you growing up as
a young lad in the UK you know you say
that you've been living there your whole
life a lot more better were you always
practicing did you always have this
dream of making films for Muslims or was
there a point where you were pulled back
to the Deen of Allah
so um so when it comes to the filmmaking
that's a very recent thing even up until
two and a half years ago I didn't even
know I was going to be a filmmaker right
but I've kind of just kind of
transitioned into that myself but in
essence bro when it comes to my whole
kind of practicing Journey alhamdulillah
boys coming up to 13 years now
um and I started very young my dad was
like a strict dear Bundy hanafi kind of
you know like father and that kind of
pushed me away from the dean because the
dean was very boring for me from the age
of like 8 9 10 11 12. I was just like it
was a chore bro because my dad like he
was practicing fresh as well
um and so he was practicing for a couple
of years and then I became a teenager
and for him the whole he had a lot of
zeal as well and as fathers when you
have a lot of zero winds up happening is
you kind of push your son into a certain
direction and it was it was a bit lousy
from him right you know I'm just be
honest right is the fact that he was he
just saw only one thing madrasa go to
madrasa no music you know like he proper
hardcore and that pushed me away bro so
from in secondary school I
unfortunately I'm not going to go into
details but unfortunately I did mess
around and um and I kind of felt that
you know I was always had this mindset
when I'm 25 30 got off the uni go ahead
blah blah blah this and that right and
so I said let me take advantage of like
all the jackalia now let me just do as
much again so I tried I did more than
the average person and I were
unfortunately really bad and uh sadly
bro you know I my my kind of experiences
with with girls and uh with music and
with other things Etc just general
advice is that as young people you have
right as a teenager growing up you know
um and I identify a lot I I then had was
in a Haram relationship with a
non-muslim
and I kind of I wanted to marry her and
what ended up happening bro was that
subhanallah you know at this point by
the way I would say I would go to the
extent of saying that I was probably
either borderline or probably like
agnostic or something like that right
just because of the fact that like my
dad would tell me to pray and I would
like splash water on my face and go
upstairs and I'm like yeah I'm going to
pray and then just go back to sleep like
as in it was just it was just like
because it's just to do it for my father
that was it
so I understand the struggle of a lot of
young Muslim results for living double
lives I really really get that pressure
right and so when it came to me my mom
subhana she caught me speaking to this
girl
and uh I said Mom what do you know about
love blah blah blah you know it's
getting emotional and it's like throwing
my toys out of the prom and uh basically
mum and dad weren't having it and they
kind of like you know said no you're not
gonna do it you're not going to get
married to her she's not a Muslim blah
blah blah and she's like why are we even
discussing this you're only 15 man
you're only 16 like what what the hell
are you gonna do getting married right
now are we going to keep above life
anyway bro I I've been said to myself
I'm gonna convert this girl to Islam all
right so uh I was and I wasn't even
practicing myself right so she was a
Hindu and so what I did was I went on
Google and I typed in how to convert
Hindu to Islam and then guess who pops
up the first person that pops up with
doctors I can like right so martial the
legend Dr Zucker like he pops up and
this is what he was quite popular 2008
10 like you know that was when he was
like really popular peace TV and stuff
and bro he's like you know like he's
like you know both a very good question
and like you know like and then you just
fire away fire away bro he'd be like you
know chapter number this verse number I
subhanallah for the first time in my
life for the first time in my life
subhanallah I thought to myself this
religion it holds value man whoa like is
is there actually evidence for this
stuff I don't know this the Quran that
had dust on my shelves bro like I picked
that for the first time and I started
reading it subhanallah and um and bro
ever since then
it's not even like that uh number one I
completely forgot that's the thing and
number two I wasn't even I wasn't home
bro so like I just got back right now so
forgive me I'm here you came at the
perfect time
emotions
no it's noise yeah so anyway I picked
the Quran up and ever since then
subhanallah like I made a vow to I said
yeah Allah I'm never gonna miss a single
prayer and yes so it was February March
of 2010 and uh ever since then bro it
just I've been practicing and a very
interesting thing subhanallah was like
because Dr Zucker Nike was my
inspiration to come to the dean
uh he is very big on Tower and so then I
started watching him use a Festus
abdrahim green Etc on peace TV like I
like you know how you just binge watch
people I was just binge watching peace
TV and um they're very big on that one
spreading Islam and so I was playing uh
like Academy level football in the UK at
the time and
I was the only Pakistani with like 45
other non-muslims here
and I start and every single one of them
I gave them the full Message of Islam
but none of them accepted it because it
was just me speaking to the crowd and
speaking to them and you know they were
just football and Lads culture in the UK
is ridiculously toxic literally it's
like this on Monday Tuesday you speak
about what you did with a girl on the
weekend on Wednesday you take a break
and on Thursday Friday you speak about
what you're gonna do with the girl on
the weekend and it's so horrible bro The
Lads culture that kind of oh like
football Lads kind of culture in the UK
is horrible so imagine trying to give
that one to them my first biggest test
of dawa was the hardest bro well like to
this day I've never given that much more
stubborn arrogant and horrible people in
my life and so because that was my first
test anything after that was easy bro so
ever since then bro the the kind of
spark and the desire to spread Islam has
always been in my heart because
it was the thing that brought me to
Islam right and uh and yeah bro like
that's that was my journey and then
Alhambra ever since then I've never kind
of stopped when it comes to kind of uh
giving that one stuff like that I've
been through my own tests with doubts
and with with super heart and problems
but bro in essence alhamdulillah man
like you know the whole journey has been
very very Blissful and Allah has blessed
me and as you grow older you mature you
know the things that you you made
mistakes with you you correct to find
them you correct them as you get older
but bro alhamdulillah yeah man I had it
I had I had a bit of a bad person when I
was younger but Allah was the one that
died and brings me to the light
I feel like I'm talking too much is is
this no no no no no
yeah you're telling the story bro so it
should be like that Allah bro if you
have any questions for us feel free you
know to jump at it no worries
I'll definitely ask you guys a few
questions
when we when we see a lot of the
segments of like the recent videos and
reels on like you know Instagram and
shorts or Tick Tock there's a lot of
stuff you're talking about with like the
family unit and marriage and masculinity
and that type of stuff so my question to
you is like why do you think this is an
extremely important thing for us to talk
about because a lot of people DM us
they're like why do you guys keep
talking about this why is there why is
it always about marriage and the family
unit you know
um so I've had the pleasure of kind of
living through the kind of uh that was
seen from 2000 and so I was by the way
I've always been involved with that one
so I've always observed what's happening
the kind of uh I keep an ear to the
ground as I say right
and I've seen this crazy transition
that in in terms of kind of uh female
strength female power feminism Etc all
this sort of stuff and I've seen things
that were
not tolerated 10 12 years ago that are
tolerated now and actually paraded and
promoted now and me oh see I'm I'm just
shy of 30 I'm 28 right and like I'm
seeing this and I'm like thinking to
myself this is this is kind of crazy man
this is this is mad like what's actually
happening and so
I actually I actually got married from
Pakistan and I actually went back home
to get married right and I've taken a
very traditional route that a lot of
people generally wouldn't do
and because I've done that I've kind of
a Handler like you know people ask me
they say how are you able to you know
run multiple businesses make a film and
like you know and yet you don't have a
job like you know like you you kind of
people people wonder how I have so much
time and I say Allah the reason I have
so much time is because of my wife
she does her role very well which is
look after the kids she makes my food
I'm not shy to say this at all she cooks
my food makes my food looks after the
kids and then when it's my time to come
and Inspire and help and be with them
it's there but I don't have the role of
now it's your day now it's your turn
it's your three hours now while I go to
my girls and I tell kind of thing and I
subhanallah I see how that Dynamic is so
successful right and Mayo allow us to
continue to be successful because I'm no
expert in marriage I'm not expert I'm
not an expert it's just the fact that I
can always speak about my experiences
and what I've observed now then I look
at some Dynamics from my friends and by
the way when I say my friends right
um that way you see online which is like
the tick tocks reels YouTube whatever
Etc that's five percent of what actually
happens in my life
95 of it is on the ground with the
brothers in my own local town and
because I have the opportunity to spend
time with a lot of young Brothers
I always spend time with young young
Brothers when it comes to Young I mean
like you know 23 and Below because I
like to kind of help bring up the Next
Generation in terms of give them a
dollar mindset and help them come on
board and we have very strong
Brotherhood in our local town as well so
I see the problem and I see their
dilemmas and I see their issues and
sticking points and I see the the the
the
pitfalls that they have when looking for
marriage and I'm seeing why is this
happening and that's why when I speak
about certain things it's not just out
of thin air it's number one relaying my
experiences and the experiences of other
brothers who have had successful
marriages and then kind of contrasting
that with the young millennial
generation that is growing up and the
pitfalls that they are having getting
married quickly getting divorced quickly
not being able to find someone suitable
and then you know uh like staying
unrated for a long time and then when
you do get with someone all these
problems are happen and I think it's
subhanallah like why is this happening
and then I realize you know what
the reality is you look at our elders
you look at our parents you look at our
grandparents stable home generally
speaking I obviously bro you have to
have your like you know uh like broken
home whatever here and there stable
marriages they stay together good family
unit solid values right
and and people say oh yeah they're just
together because the kids let me tell
you something you know subhanallah yeah
the reality is is that the direction
that we are going in bro in terms of our
ourselves as a generation and in terms
of where our direction is going in terms
of morality you you can see the flawed
uh nature of of what we are living in
right now the society will live you can
see the flaws in it you see it's full of
holes bro and so therefore we have no
right to claim and say that what we are
doing and what we are living through is
correct we have to look at those who
have come before so I have successful
marriages and that's why I always
promote be good respecting your parents
listen to your elders you want to take
marriage advice go listen to them go and
find out what they say and Allah if we
do not live with our elders and with our
with our shoe you cannot without
teachers and if we have no one to keep
us grounded bro Allah who the hell are
we to actually give advice to people we
are living through the same crap of
social media that these youngsters are
living through the people that have had
a clean upbringing are the ones older
than us and therefore when I say to
listen to them and be more traditional
it's not because I'm just saying do that
it's because their model has worked and
ours is failing miserably and so
therefore does it not just make sense to
listen to them or just give them an ear
and give them a few seconds and
understand what they're trying to tell
you so when I put these things out bro
it's not because oh I'm just trying to
you know get one over the youngsters
whoever know
all of my friendship circles about 80 90
100 whatsoever all of them they all are
younger than me most of the majority
right and they all listen to my advice
and they understand it and we talk about
these things in our Gatherings all the
time but the reality is is that locker
room talk with Brothers never comes
online that's the problem because I feel
that the machetech they want to win
points for the sisters and so what we
find is that that locker room talk that
chat that Brothers have by themselves
with themselves when they're sitting
down right over some kahua whatever bro
they're chilling and talking no one is
bringing up to the full so sisters
really don't get to understand what is
going through the brother psyche what is
going through their mind what what
problems they're going through what
their thought process is and so what
ends up happening is sisters have this
fantasy one that they're living in and
then the brothers are just listening to
Michelle saying brother bend over
backwards and you know what I mean
listen to your wife and if you if you
move to the right you move to the right
if he does this we do that and the
sisters are like oh my God I love this
[ __ ] amazing and then all of a sudden
bro you have a mismatch where Brothers
trying to lift through his true
masculinity and his true nature as a man
and he wants to be the king of the house
but then you as a woman for example
listen to to to to the current narrative
which is you know go out there be be be
you know a big bad babe boss whatever it
is right do your thing go you go you go
you yeah man more power to use this and
then all of a sudden the brothers
they're misky on the side just like you
know oh cool I gotta live through this
crap now I love you bro that's that's
what we're living through so
so but I I don't want to get too
passionate about this oh you know what
Allah
we are seeing an epidemic right now and
I feel not enough people are speaking
about this unfiltered and I feel like
bro when people do have the courage to
speak unapologetically and transparently
about this they're they're being labeled
you know shaming tactics like misogynist
they get it this for that for you know
I agree bro and I and you know what it
is brother
problem here is that
you say this I still
say that the love online and the
attention on iron boy is all Bs bro like
you probably notice I don't come I don't
reply to any comments At All YouTube
Instagram I don't reply to any comments
because bro like I don't have time to go
through this number one number two bro
everyone has an opinion some random guy
from Indonesia bro he's like brother if
this is not correct and you're like like
okay cool man like you got you that's
fine you say your peace bro but my job
is to put the content out whoever it
resonates with alhamdulillah if people
don't like it the unfollow button says
well
you know and I think we have to have all
more more mental strength when it comes
to online bro I feel that a lot of
youngsters are too attached to a like a
shirt a reaction oh someone's speaking
against
this is this is the online World bro
sadly bro we are we are becoming too
fixated on a touch fit man well forgive
us man Allah I mean I mean and you
you'll find this trend like whenever you
know something becomes popular socially
even in the non-muslim world that that
same thing tends to become popular
within the Muslim world as well and I'm
not going to sit here and act like you
don't have you know uh men who harm
their wives and daughters right like
that exists 100 but now we're falling
into another extreme which is instead of
being a tyrant be like like a servant
slave like would do whatever your wife
wants and not only is that harmful to
the relationship just like the reverse
was but that's harmful to her as a woman
and you as a man because a woman
naturally does not want to be a leader a
lot of the time and a man naturally
needs to be the leader needs to feel
like the man and even like you'll have
cases where like a woman you know she
will she will cook it and clean for her
husband after a long time and she will
say like I feel like a wife now now I
feel like a woman and you'll have a man
who takes charge and takes care of
things and he'll be like wow I feel like
a man like this is just basic normal
stuff but a lot of the non-muslim world
Creeps in well let me let me jump in let
me jump in real quick because I wanted
to add this point because I feel like
what we're saying is very true but also
there are some people out here you know
there are some people that take things a
little bit out of context and we should
say that this doesn't mean don't help
your wife whenever she does need some
help because the prophet Muhammad sallam
he helped his wife
he healed his wife so like if we are not
helping wives and what what are we are
we better than him of course not so it's
like again this is for the people who
are you know taking out of context but I
understand everything it's it's the
extremism that's happening today was the
men are almost being forced to do the
women's role and the women love being
forced to do the the men's role so I
just want to clarify that no no bro
you're 100 right man everything is said
with that disclaimer brother
the reality his bro is when when a
narrative gains traction it goes
overboard naturally that's that's just
how it happens bro you know people don't
know where to draw the boundary because
you're you're riding a wave and you
don't know where to stop and so the
problem is is that once something gains
momentum people don't know where the
boundaries are because the boundaries
are fresh you know you need to make the
boundaries and that's why I believe and
I respect you guys as well for speaking
about this subject because what you're
trying to do is trying to bring those
boundaries in let's say okay cool yeah
like there is abuse with a problem
without a shadow of that there's abuse
bro but you know speaking about that
that's fine raise awareness of that no
problem but the reality is is that we
are now going to the Other Extreme as
well where basically we are uh you know
too shy and too too nervous to speak
about uh the actual kind of like you
know the divorce rates that we currently
have and listen listen don't get it
twisted divorce didn't happen the time
the professor but divorce then is not
the same as the divorce today culturally
speaking we have to be honest with
ourselves yeah divorce that is not the
same as divorce today divorce today you
know Francis they can ruin her you know
and and and that's the problem and
that's what we're trying to curb broken
homes bro this is crazy statistic bro is
that like over 90 of of inmates in
prison are from broken homes why why is
that it's because there's no stability
you need to have some a stable
relationship and so
like as in a woman as you said around me
like she wants to feel like you know
she's a she's a wife so like when your
wife cooks for you bro be a man and
compliment her praise her when she
cleans the room and she's like you know
like mashallah can you see the room like
yeah like that's amazing wow thank you
so much I appreciate you like don't be a
lousy guy as well man that's the other
thing as well like brothers think that
that's the other thing bro now what's
happening bro now what's happening here
especially with Andrew tray another few
other people as well that kind of
pushing this now what's happening is
that it's the opposite it sort of slowly
we're on this trajectory now bro we're
on this trajectory and when that happens
people again because it's fresh people
don't know where to draw the boundaries
bro and what this masculinity narrative
does not mean is that you be a lousy
husband you be immature you throw your
socks like you know and don't pick them
up Etc you take care of yourself man
have a responsibility have it yourself
for your own self bro I mean imagine if
people what you see like the way you
behave bro like you know how do you feel
then like I said don't be it don't be
lousy don't be you know at the end of
the day if she's struggling with
something help her man this poor woman
left her home to come and live with you
you know so they we have to at the same
time be fair but none of us are experts
man so we're just trying to do our best
to kind of help the youngsters inshallah
and we're going to have flaws in us
we're going to have mistakes and we just
ask for Allah to forgive us for our
errors and mistakes and for people to
overlook them as well you know because
at the end of the day whatever narrative
we push on whatever we promote and say
is all it always can be right and can be
wrong and as my Malik said that the only
person that is correct is the is the
companion of this grave when he was
speaking about the prophet sallam so
he's the only one that's infallible bro
so at the end of the day everyone else
has flaws and kind of mistakes as well
you know so we ask a lot for for
assistance and guidance on me Allah I
mean Allah I mean and actually that's
that's a big point that I wanted to to
bring up as well that's why it's so
important like fundamentally important
for people to learn Islam because when
they learn Islam they learn what to do
in situations when you learn what they
do in situations you don't have to
result to your own mess stop psyche
that's going to tell you because you're
you're traumatized for what happened 20
years ago it's going to make you respond
in this way like people don't understand
like the amount of of kids that were
traumatized by their parents and not in
the way some some in very horrible ways
because the parents are just messed up
but some in very subtle ways like the
dad wasn't there enough the dad didn't
you know communicate with them enough or
the mom was a little too sometimes she's
there sometimes she's like disappearing
you know those things create abandonment
issues attachment issues you know even
issues with with developing love and and
connections like all these things that
break marriages in the future and it's
me and my wife are talking about it's so
easy to mess up a child even the mom
like when it's a baby even like an
infant and it's crying if you pick up
your baby every single time it cries it
may develop attachment issues yeah
because every single time even if it
doesn't need anything you just want to
be a brat like a little baby brat and
wants to cry because babies do that if
you pick it up your teaching is
something that's bad and if you never
pick it up obviously you're messing up
your baby as well so it's like it's so
easy to mess up a child imagine when you
add to that oppression and tyranny and
and do this and do that and all these
horrible things you're messing people up
so when you take it back to the dean you
see how the prophetam was with this with
his grandchildren you had a man who came
from he saw him kiss his grandson on the
forehead he's like you kiss your you
kiss your grandkids he's like yeah in
the man's like I have like 10 or 12
grandkids I never kiss any of them you
know what the process said he said
whoever does not show Mercy does not
receive Mercy meaning from Allah
this is so key as well we have to be
affectionate bro to our daughters
especially to our sons yes but to our
daughters especially bro because in
today's world bro there are strange men
who will show affection to your daughter
when she's older and she will run to
that because she never received you did
from you she has to feel a sense of love
and belonging and bro especially in
today's day and age what we can't do is
make the mistake of yes we love the
traditional folk and the Traditional
Values Etc but we are living in a modern
world and we have to try and mold
ourselves and adapt in a certain way to
make sure that at the same time when we
do speak to our children and we do raise
them it's to understand and understand
the culture that they live in and to
understand that you have to do things
with subtleties you have to be very
careful you have to try and do the right
things as well and Allah you have to
show love kiss them hug them show them
affection I say this here and I'm like
you know it's not part of masculinity to
not show your sensitive side bro you
know you know my my brothers yeah they
will who I know they're all watching
this right
my friends in my community every single
one of them have received a kiss on the
cheek from me right why is that and
subhanallah I don't do it because oh I'm
just doing it I will like I do because I
love them I love them and I tell them
that I love them for Allah's sake and I
genuinely do that bro and wallahi if
you're a day this is this is something
that I've wanted to say for a while if
you're a day if you spread Islam if you
and then you are someone that does not
have compassion and love for people
you're doing the wrong job
if you do not have love and compassion
and Mahaba and genuine softness for your
fellow man for your fellow brother
why would you want to save them from the
Hellfire what the hell man that's the
whole purpose of that is to save people
from Johannes and that can only come and
be born out of a genuine curve and
that's why it's so important that when
we are people that are online and
throughout our online it's so important
that you remove yourself from that and
go and live with people it's going to
sit in the master with your elders just
sit in the masters with the shabab build
something with them have a vision with
your local community because that is way
more important than trying to build
something online online bro you could
just it's cameras rights action bro it's
cameras rights action thumbnail click
clickbait that's all it is really
intruding right yeah everyone's fighting
over that cloud but when it comes to and
to to real life and the cameras are off
that's when you have to truly you know
love people and build that connection
and obviously you're just leading on
from that whole masculinity kind of
discussion is that when it comes to when
it comes to being a man it doesn't mean
you don't show emotion doesn't mean you
don't show care it doesn't mean you
don't show you know mercy and tenderness
towards your your brothers and your
people you have to have that bro look at
a properly side or something what he
said when he was going to Yemen he said
I love you he walked with him to the
outskirts of Marina he said oh what I
love you subhanallah you know he's
telling his companions that he loves
them bro if a man does this now bro or
you look up we we look him up and down
be like oh bro you're right here you're
okay like that's hard that's why bro
like we have to be examples of
development we have to show that love
and care and tenderness as well man you
know what I mean yeah bro
I think I think that's beautiful man
um I also think that it's crazy how if
you get deep into Islam you start to
understand more like what actual
masculinity is
uh because before Islam bro I had such a
twisted understanding of what
masculinity was and I I feel like I had
to kind of figure it out on my own but
once I came to this land it's like wow
it's it's so simple it's all been there
from the beginning and then like Rami
was saying like we do certain things and
then as we do it we have this innate
feeling like ah this feels right this
feels like exactly how it should feel
you know so alhamdulillah
and um
I gotta I gotta go guys I gotta go pray
I'm so sorry I
I'm so sorry honestly I didn't I did not
mean to come late today
well I I hope you can forgive me for
this and um bro I didn't even get your
name what's your name bro my name is
Sharpe
should I
myself you're gonna you're gonna give us
a kiss on the cheek when you see us
well I love y'all for the sake of Allah
uh may Allah accept all your praise and
to us and assalamu alaikum so
um bro honestly bro you reminded me of
of it's like you unlock the memory for
me subhanallah when I was younger I had
this like childhood friend he was a
non-muslim but uh you know I was I was
very close to me I consider him a really
close friend um like I introduced them
in a way to basketball and he became so
good at that honestly he was better than
me uh very fast you know Allah and
um yeah that's how close this guy was to
me and I was at his house a lot of the
time you know playing basketball and
stuff and one day I was outside his
house on the porch with them and my
brother called me I don't remember why
but I was in Middle School right I was
like grade seven or something grade
eight
and my brother calls me and we're
talking and at the end he says I love
you or I say I love you or something
like that you know I love you love you
too bye and the guy looks at me you know
he's a young white guy he looks at me
he's like you say you you say I love you
to your brother
and I'm like I'm a young guy I'm like
yeah yeah he's like man that's weird
I never said it since I stopped saying
it that day now recently I went back to
it and I'm upset that that kind of thing
affected me that much but I stopped
saying it because of that bro and that
honestly that breaks my heart
yeah man you know well lucky bro when it
comes to your brothers and the people
that you're around I I have to be honest
with you bro there is a heightened sense
of loneliness in the world today bro big
time and it's it's really playing on
people bro I'll tell you why two reasons
here
social media creates that illusion that
everyone's making moves everyone's going
places that everyone's progressing and
doing stuff for their lives yeah because
you have this you have this small little
window right and this window is what
anyone gets to project onto you
but you don't see that real true picture
that creates a void within it within
your heart thinking I am incapable I am
lacking I am falling behind I am not
doing the things that other people are
doing
and then you also have this kind of uh
innate desire to feel loved
and a lot of the times bro parents are
too busy working earning money you know
especially fathers they don't have the
time to show love to their children
and I can say loads of things about my
father and say how he didn't do this
right he didn't do that right whatever
but one thing that my father always used
to do was just stop pause and give us a
kiss
sometimes and just kiss me and he said
you know you're the best thing that ever
happened to me
and and I would think to myself wow man
like subhanallah that um a man like my
father who's like probably Macho over
now he can pause and he can do that
and that taught me bro and then I would
go and do it to my friends and my
brothers who are around me
and
I can say I can I can truly say this
you're like I say this with chess for
you
in the UK I feel that what we have in
our local town is the best Brotherhood
in the whole of the UK
and I well I truly fully fully believe
that because we have brothers from
London that come and see us and brothers
from Birmingham the two biggest cities
in the UK and they say what you have
here we've never seen it anywhere else
we feel more love here than we do
anywhere else and the reason that Israel
is because
we we make an emphasis to show each
other love and care and talk to each
other and spend time with each other
everyone is important no one is Left
Behind no one is sidelined you know how
what ends up happening is people create
Clicks in Islamic brotherhoods they
create clicks there's like you know oh
me and my three friends me my four
friends and that's when things get a bit
boring and the Heart softness and the
reminders get boring and you four start
to think oh is this what is he like this
is that like you know and you get bored
because that's that's the subject that
you have over like you know a cafe a
late at night like you know your wives
that are at home wherever and you're
there sat there thinking oh this brother
give a talk there but
I start picking picking holes at people
right we have a very conducive
Brotherhood that grows every single year
bro yeah Allah he grows to the point
where we we have way too many people to
invite to events we have way too many
people we can't fit them in the events
now and and subhanallah the reason that
is the ethosa is the number one because
of that one everyone is focused on
spreading Islam on on on getting the
it's not Islam through to the Next
Generation and number two there is a
genuine care and love for every single
person and there is a zero tolerance for
bullying zero tolerance well he brought
one time here
in our Gatherings there was this one
brother who you know nerds bro nerds
geeking kind of like just like scrawny
guys skinny guys sitting in the corner
like like kind of like that he's there
he's in our gathering he makes a joke
and and no one laughs and some of the
brothers they take the mick out of him
and in the middle of this Gathering I
say Brothers I have to mention it to you
guys right now what Allah what you have
done is poison
yeah you guys are comfortable because
there's three four of you here right now
and you guys are mocking him right he's
trying to find some acceptance and love
from you guys and look at what you're
doing
be ashamed of yourself and I've said
that to brothers who are really close to
me and subhanallah like from there
people learned the lesson that when you
come back by in this friendship group
you can't you can't mock somebody in
this friendship group and this
friendship group is all about love and
progression and helping people and
developing the Iman and if you go on
like my tick tock on Instagram you will
see like videos of us around the
campfire
Etc having reminders and other videos
and reminders and stuff for that as well
and like subhanallah we try and create a
very heart softening environment man
there's always going to be flaws and
problems with us but you know
subhanallah bro I can say truly say that
alhamdul we have that and I feel a lot
of duat a lot of do actually try and
focus on this as well as their online
that way as well because that when you
focus on that when you truly focus on
the ground reality
because you see people you see the
people that have been misguided you see
the people that are running towards the
Hellfire and you see their problems
where you talk to them you can feel them
hug them bro you can have that real
conversation
and that's when you're able to think why
am I making this video why am I putting
this reminder out why am I doing so I'm
doing this and you just subhanallah I
want people to go to gender man I want
people to enter Paradise because I truly
love people and I say this to all my
brothers and I say your mission and aim
in life is you get to paralyze and take
as many people as you can with you that
should be the aim nothing will ever
prompt that as a vision and a name and
um and Allah people also for that reason
bro masculinity can be toxic if you
don't understand it correctly look at
the prophet salallahu look at how he
empowered his companions by telling him
he loves them
what did he say the man who couldn't
even look at the prophet sallam when he
when he accepted Islam because to before
Islam the prophet saws was the most
hated person in his eyes and armor said
he said that the Popstar son was the
most hated then he became the most
beloved and I if you ask me to describe
him I would not be able to describe him
because I didn't even look at his face
and he was the purpose of Solomon he
thought he was the most beloved
companion of the process who do you love
the most he said Aisha he said among
someone he said so her father then he
said okay okay yeah cool I'll get it
I'll get it I'll be back in your closest
companion he did take you out with you I
get it okay who next oh no yeah okay
cool I get that um
I stopped asking because I thought that
you know I would never be mentioned but
to me I felt he loved me the most
so that's what masculinity is bro
masculinity isn't just being mature and
being like yeah man let's work out let's
do like let's let's do like fighting
let's fight and let's grappling let's
beat people up and let's be like spread
your shoulders true masculinity is
having care and love for your brother by
understanding your roles and
responsibility as a man inside your home
as well man and we're all full of flaws
bro so maybe I'll just waffled on and
all of this is
beautiful one like 100 and actually it
kind of touches on a point one dimension
as well when it comes to you know
manhood masculinity you know what is a
man you have a lot of this discussion
like what is a man supposed to be no
what defines a man and I think it's such
it's it's almost such a dumb question
because it's like subhanallah we've
gotten so far from who we really are
that we have to ask you know like soon
we're gonna be asking what is a human
being you know because people don't
identify as humans anymore and that's
again again
but if you look at you know the process
in them as the guideline for who is a
man you'll come to understand that
basically a man is who he needs to be in
the situation he's given it depends on
what situation you're in if you're you
know if someone's being attacked in that
moment as a man you need to go defend
them you need to be you know harsh you
need to be rough you need to like beat
this guy up basically but if your
daughter is coming running crying to you
you're not going to use that same energy
with her you're going to go you're going
to be compassionate you're going to be
you know protective you're going to love
her you're going to have that compassion
with her because she's your daughter or
if your son comes crying the same thing
might be slight variation slight
differences but it's going to be
essentially the same compassion and love
and mercy towards your children you know
same thing with your wife and
subhanallah like
it's crazy man people people will be
like no a man needs to be rough all the
time so he'll look at his son be like
stop crying be a man grow up it's like
bro my wife is telling me this the other
day when I was when we're having this
this discussion she was like you know be
careful because you're still talking to
a kid we had different ideas different
ages in mind I was thinking more like 11
year old she was thinking more like
four-year-old but she's right you're not
going to go to four you'll be like be a
man you're still talking to a kid well
like and people need to understand that
about masculine about being a man
we have to truly understand that being a
man isn't about just
being harsh
yes
and you see his personality but do you
know once he became a Khalifa he was
harder on himself than he was on anyone
else and he was only harsh because that
was the only way he could really Express
his sincerity and love for Islam and he
was so careful about Innovation and he
was so careful about all these things
that would misguide people bro that's
why he was harsh in those regards to
defend Islam but he wasn't harsh with
the Believers he was so soft with the
Believers he was so soft there was a man
always a colony who came from Yemen and
uh and you know the professor spoke
about he mentioned that when Oasis comes
you know
um may ask him to make Dua for you
and subhanallah because
he came to Medina and uh and you know he
was special he honored him he loved him
he was so soft with him bro he gave you
gifts and subhanallah like you know
anyone who is loved by Allah anyone
who's a Believer you should have that
tenderness towards them and that's why
Allah says in the Quran
right is right you know so you have
Zilla you have humility you have this
sense of tenderness with the believer
and this sense of strength in the eyes
of the disbeliever you know and so this
is why it's it's a Sunnah that we've
forgotten bro and that's why I feel I
feel that to draw the boundaries of
masculinity which is definitely a
challenge and I'd encourage and urge you
guys as well always to make sure to
mention these things as well as
mentioning you know what a real man is
you know and again you know we all have
mistakes and we're all gonna we're all
going through this age of social media
together man so you know this is all new
to all of us man so we just ask a lot to
guide our path and keep us Uprising bro
I think this is a wonderful segue to
kind of go into you know marriage and
the whole structure and parenting and
all that to be honest bro how I found
you was on my explore page there came
this this I think it was a reel that you
posted going to Jeremiah with your with
your daughter right it was like the
first one you took your daughter and you
were mentioning that you know recently
you've changed and fine-tuned a little
bit about your approach and delivery
with your children and your daughter
namely so do you want to go a little bit
into that
so this is quite deep bro but basically
with my son
with my son uh he was a little bit more
spoiled because he was the first
child grandchild great grandchild for
our whole family
he was the star of a new generation for
everyone he leveled everyone up my son
right
so what ended up happening he got a lot
of attention and I realized that and I
sensed that he was getting a big cow to
eat so there would be times that he's
two years old and he's crying and I'd
grab him Adam stop this right now and
I'd shake him up a little bit right and
he'd like
like you know he'd do that and
subhanallah like that was tough love and
I would not do it often but I did it
sometimes and he learned bro and he
slowly started understanding that I
can't get away with certain crap I can't
always just you know throw my toys out
of the pram like you know
um and so then I was doing the same with
my daughter I locked the door and I just
grabbed it I said Samaya stop this now
and subhanallah she kept on crying and
this just get got worse and worse and
worse and bro I'm telling you
I was thinking that she's like my son
but that's not the case bro
and I don't know if this is the case for
everyone like everyone's children is
different the psyche is everyone
different right this is just purely my
experience
subhanallah bro
I started showing her more love more
attention more care like tomorrow
sometimes I'm editing
or I'm working or whatever I'm doing and
she'll come to me like Daddy Let's play
catch
or did any of us feed Miriam she's got a
dog that's called Miriam and I'd come
with him okay mariam's like milk has run
out go get the milk and like you know
would play and like we'd have fun at
life and I would just silly stupid
things with my daughter right but she
loves that bro she absolutely she craves
her and my daughter never came up to me
and gave me a hug until two months ago
and now she does it every single day
because she sees that Daddy is a safe
space for me
that he's he's tenderhearted with me and
I would excuse mistakes of my daughter
more than I'd excuse mistakes of my son
and what Allah he brought I realize that
daughters need to be loved and taken
care of and honorable and really looked
after and subhanallah like there's been
certain sisters that have have discussed
and I've seen the discussion where they
haven't felt love from their father and
that is one of the biggest mistakes and
one of the biggest reasons that girls
look for love elsewhere
and they become unstable and they have
marriages that are unstable because
they've never had love and when love
does come to them they don't know how to
manage it and that's why if you show
your daughter love from a young age she
will not crave it from other people and
that's why there may be things where you
may need to scold her but you excuse it
for the benefit of just showing your due
to that love and that care and I feel
that's where subhanallah for me I
realize that
it's not about being heavy-handed it's
not about showing strength with your
daughter Allah I'd realize that it's
more about tenderness and gentleness and
love and compassion when it comes to
your daughter and that's the biggest
thing I learned bro and I'm glad I
learned here and she's only two years
old
um because if I learned this later on I
know sometimes it can be too late bro
and wallahi sometimes once damage is
done it can be very hard to reverse
because girls they remember pain bro
go they remember the pain that they went
through and especially if they're a
teenager a young teenager were lucky
these are the most traumatizing the the
body is changing Everything's changed
the REM they associate so many emotions
with this and those emotions if they are
negative they will Harbor them and it
will be their anchor for the rest of
their life no matter how much you be
good to them after that and that's why
it's so important that if you have young
daughters Allah my message to the
fathers out there is to cherish them and
love them and be compassionate with them
and to know and look at the example of
your Nabi when Fatima came into the room
he would get up and he went forward and
he kissed her on the forehead and he
told her to sit next to him you think
you're a man by ignoring her you think
you're a man by being heavy-handed by
telling her oh stop I mean there's being
a traditional old father that's not how
it works and that's why it's so so
important to show your children that
love you know we are flawed as human
beings the thing that we don't need is
for our family to hate us as for our
family not to love us because that's one
love that you need as a man you need
that love and I did not know how much I
needed my daughter's love until she gave
it to me bro when she comes up to me and
she said Daddy and hugs me and this
grabs me I'm telling you man bro bro bro
you don't understand that love there
it replaces everything bro it replaces
everything it fills a void and I didn't
know me I consider myself very mentally
strong
but bro it filled a void in me that I
didn't even know existed bro
subhanallah
sorry guys I'm getting a bit deeper man
but yeah
you guys are both okay I already muted
bro
I got so much Insight from the Instagram
reel itself and then just hearing like
the backstory and everything going down
with the contacts and the Lessons
Learned in the wisdom bro it's it's a
game changer man and I don't have kids
too none of this around me on her yet so
in Charlotte it's good to know these
things you know before having it
inshaallah because but at the end of the
day too you don't want to get stuck into
like paralysis by analysis you know
parenting is also something that you
learn as you go there's only so much we
can learn beforehand
um but in in terms of to the husbands
now what advice would you have like
things that you've really picked up on
in like the last few years in your
marriage okay perfect so
um so I I've been married before I was
married when I was 18 and the
relationship didn't work out
and I got married from the UK so I I
understand
when
and by the way it wasn't entirely her
fault or my bro I take a big risk big
chunk of that responsibility for life
massive chunk
and um I I'm not going to talk about her
flaws but I'll tweak my mind yeah
the biggest throws that I had as a man
was number one I was broke bro
I was broke you know I had a pink
bicycle don't ask why it's pink right by
the Pink Bicycle right and um and I'd go
I'd go like you know and you know go and
we would go together on that like you
know like I'd be like just walking with
my bike bro like it was embarrassing but
man you know what I mean and um and and
I'm just being honest with you bro like
when you don't have money we don't have
these things bro really Intruder you
can't truly be the man
and so in essence
that was the thing that I said to myself
I will never ever ever ever ever go back
to that what I don't care what happens
I'm never gonna be broke again the
trauma that I had from that bro stay
looting for the rest of my life you know
and alhamdulillah blessed me to kind of
never worry about money again and that's
the first thing is that you have to try
if you want to be a man if you want
stamp your Authority you need to be
earning the bread bro
right you need to be you need you need
to be getting the money bro and that's
that's very very important the second
thing bro
is when I give advice to you young
Brothers especially when they're looking
for marriage and those who are married
you need to know your personality you
need to know what type of a character
you are how are you as a person are you
someone that is strong-minded
opinionated and
basically likes the sound of their own
voice
and wants to be heard
and or are you someone that's
tender-hearted goes with the flow easy
to get on with anyone right and I'm I'm
the I'm the former right I'm very
opinionated right and I have kind of
natural leadership qualities that just
overtake you at times
and so I realized that if I want to
marry someone I need to marry someone
that's tender-hearted and shy submissive
Etc and that is one of the main reasons
why I got married from Pakistan
because naturally it's built in within
them this element of service you to the
husband this shyness to the husband
right this humidity towards the husband
it's honoring the husband and the man of
your of your of your house
and so that's what the dynamic between
me and my wife works
along those best words going to end up
and if it's going to be successful long
term but so far so good are we asking us
to protect you from the evil eye and to
to to to protect us from any type of
Fitness well I mean but in essence
that's that you need to know who you are
and if you're a soft-hearted person then
yeah like as in yeah you know your kind
of restriction on what you desire what
you want in terms of the personality of
your wife are different
but as a man generally speaking most men
have these qualities most men want to be
heard most men want to be respected most
men want to have the law say
and if you are of that type if you are
that personality then you need to know
and realize what you're looking for in a
wife and what you're looking for in the
marriage and what you're looking for
when you search for marriage because Hot
and Hot together is just going to create
a blaze cold and cold together it's just
going to give you frostbite hot and cold
together will create the perfect
temperature
and so the reality is that
marriage is about stability and balance
you need to complement each other's
weaknesses and strengths and that's the
first thing I'd say and while he the
second thing the most important thing is
never get marriage advice from just one
person it's speak to your elders and
speak to those who have been in the
successful mind for over 20 years
because they know better and my advice
is simply me projecting my own personal
subjective opinion onto others and hence
why when I speak and when I say certain
things it's purely my own limited
experience which is totally flawed and
full of biases and full of so many other
things so take you with a pinch of salt
listen to other brothers listen to other
people and when you are married and the
brothers that are married
okay I'll be honest with you uh when it
comes to marriage advice I'm not the
best person to ask purely because of the
fact that you know I can be a lousy
husband as well but the biggest thing
that I learned in marriage from my first
failed one to mind one that's not
currently I'm I married 100 seven years
is
maturity bro maturity
keep this shot at times not everything
needs to be won now every argument needs
to be one not everything needs to be
fixed certain things let them slide let
them go I remember bro subhanallah there
were times when I first married but when
like
she'd drop off should drop the face
towel that I used to wash my face with
and like she'd use it on her dryer hair
and drop it on the floor
I'd be like what the hell like that's my
face told I'm gonna get spots and you
need to know what you shouldn't argue
about you need to know what to just
slide bro I'm just like women
right women love drama women will get
into drama so easily bro you know but
the reality is you need to know and be
mature enough to know what battles you
need to win or what battle you don't
need to win and most of them you don't
need to win and most of them you don't
need to get into and most of them can be
avoided bro well he sometimes I'll be
arguing with my wife and then I'm
thinking why how did it I don't even get
here how did this argument even start
I forgot my point and then I just ah
sorry I'm sorry like you know what I
mean and so the reality is bro is that
you need to have the wisdom and the
maturity to understand that you're not
going to get everything right
and that's why it's important to learn
on the job and to get advice and be
amongst people who are Elder than you
older than you
man I don't care who hates this advice
but you need to have Elder murabies you
need to have Elder people around you to
help you trust me to navigate through
this journey of life you're only 21 22
23 24 whatever this is fresh bro no on
the next but not me none of us
so have your elders
what is the saying that this used to say
that be with your elders saying in
Arabic but be with your elders be with
your Messiah be with the oldest because
they have lived through what you have
lived through and they have wisdom that
cannot be taught
you may have followers bro I've got
followers I've got whatever you want to
call it right I've got an opinion I
don't have wisdom I don't have eight on
my side and that's why it's so important
that when he does come to marriage
advice you take it from the elders you
take it from people who have been there
and been successful and don't take it
from young people who are inexperienced
and this is why I like to sometimes
police the conversations of my younger
brothers my friends
when they start getting a bit carried
away like bro yeah man that girl
probably I'm like boys real absolutely
yeah like you are just getting carried
away with certain things yeah and
sometimes like to police that because
sometimes they need to know as well that
it's not all a Bed of Roses once you get
married and I just made a video the
other day as well about that you know I
said well like once you smell their
thoughts man all those dreams are gone
but all those dreams are gone that's it
you know that that that that fantasy
picture that you've got the Romantic
idea of love
yeah have that but bro that's not be all
an end all of marriage and once the
ideas and the fantasies die out you're
thinking this is dry man well I go if
you talk to this person you've got a
quick conversation you know and that's
why subhanallah like I feel that it's
important have the right expectations
going into marriage and once you are
married always have the right people
around you to give you good positive
advice as well and if there are any
sisters listening my biggest advice for
you sisters biggest advice to you if you
are a young sister and you are trying to
get married or you are married
have Elder sisters senior I'm not
talking 25 24 27 who have just like been
married two three years where I haven't
got one child and you know they're like
you know posting pictures I'm not
talking about them talking the elders
sisters in the community 35 Plus 40 plus
four or five kids Etc the kids are like
you know teenagers ask them
what should I do because wallahi the
advice will always come back honor your
husband
honor your husband respect your husband
be there for him Etc and they will tell
you when abuse and tolerance is getting
too much if you are getting abused if
you are getting bullied if you are
having problems in your marriage then
you will be the one to tell you don't
listen to his young sister who if your
husband says I want you to King for me
how abuse man uh that toxic husband blah
blah blah you're an abused sister no
that's that's not what that's not the
right friends you need to be around be
with the elders bro Allah that's that's
my biggest advice because I can't really
give marriage advice for because I'm
still learning on the job right now man
so forgive me for I'll give you a happy
answer but that's generally what I would
say
that was sufficient enough I do want to
zero in now um one of the final topics
before we do wrap up unless Romney has
anything else you you mentioned the
importance and and how pivotal it is to
to make bread and to have money not be
Reliant or dependent on something
because money at the end of the day
money isn't the nrbo but it is a means
to not sacrifice your honor and
integrity to have the ability to travel
do whatever you want to do live life on
a little bit more in your your own terms
and with that responsibility if you do
it right you can come close to Allah so
how did you get to this point at what
point would you have and I want to give
a disclaimer guys it's not Financial
advice we don't want any lawsuits or
anything like that but what advice would
you have when it comes to money
perfect bro so a lot of people don't
know this and I guess maybe I've been a
bit quiet about this because I don't
like to speak about my financial things
medical attacks man but also at the same
time right you know when it comes to
online there's a lot of Hazard and stuff
like that as well but seeing as
obviously um
you guys have asked me uh alhamdulillah
Allah has blessed me to to earn six
figures and be in a position where I've
kind of uh alhamdulillah had the
pleasure of earning a good amount of
money you don't have the little bro and
I'm still strengthening these uh income
streams as we go along
um and so I've realized something bro
that is that you know firstly if you
want respect from your woman if you want
to respect for your wife as you said
freedom to travel live life in your own
terms Etc you need to be earning money
you need to be earning money and I
didn't have I don't have a degree
neither I have any kind of massive
qualifications or skills or anything
like that so I've learned hustle from
the down up and my advice when it comes
to money bro and alhamdulillah like you
know I give this advice to my younger
brothers is not to depend on one source
of income that's the first thing in this
world not to depend on what source of
income diversify your income and what
you should do is experiment with
different hustles what you need to do is
this one of the biggest advice I'd give
put aside two three hundred pounds right
every single month and that you do not
touch that money that money is
experiment money and you do not have an
emotional attachment to that money that
money it will simply be to experiment
different hustles with and what you do
with that once you save up and you try
and and then what you do you see if a
hustle works you see if a business works
you see if this happens up and you may
go through 10 different opportunities
than the 1100 strike and then you use
that and then you start scaling that one
you start growing that one that's how
you do it alhamdulillah I have about
five six businesses right now
I'm just opening my sixth one up now uh
it's a Smokehouse uh like Texas barbecue
Smokehouse kind of thing
um and uh and and bro like as it's fun
like you know um
and this is this is something like you
know I remember you guys know SQ right
you guys know SQ right so so
um SQ is you know he does hijama he does
he sells zamzam Etc and uh you know
sq's wife lives uh she's like my
neighbor pretty much in the UK uh so it
was me who taught ask you how to do
hijama right and like helping him on
that Journey Etc I said to everyone bro
you gotta just just try to just do it
bro as well and look at excuse or
somebody followers like you know someone
that subscribes on YouTube but he's
doing hijama he's doing this hustle he
gets it bro he gets it you know you
shouldn't be embarrassed bro to do
certain things and so I did a few things
and hijama popped for me so now I'm just
starting to scale that I I try different
selling different things and zamzam and
I draw dates Etc I do that in Ramadan I
make you know good money in Ramadan I I
go all out in that in that small period
of time and that keeps me running for a
couple of months then I've got my other
kind of you know uh that I do as well uh
with a few Brothers as well
alhamdulillah I've got kind of a share
in that as well and you know that at
work you you work hard at your hustle
you do it but bro it's not going to be
easy when I was in 2016 bro I was um I
was driving a banged up micro bro I was
driving a banged up micro I had no money
I I was just starting out bro and and
then as you grow older like people will
see me now was like like a nice Range
Rover or a nice car whatever Etc but
they don't understand that where you are
is where you are don't compare yourself
to other people run your own race you
are on your own Journey your own track
get your head down and focus and also
also also
once you start your hustles never ever
spend more than your old lifestyle live
within your means one of the biggest
problems that youngsters have is the the
start a business and get hustle and they
don't have enough money to restock or
they don't have enough because they're
spending that money the worst thing you
can do in your 20s is buy an expensive
car the worst thing
and you need to understand this is this
is like you know Financial education is
so important liabilities and assets and
I would recommend the book reached out
pulled out to people where basically you
understand anything that is taking money
out of your bank account well you know
what I I didn't understand how simple
this is but a lot of people just don't
understand it
lower your liabilities lower your
outgoings and increase your assets
increase your assets and don't feel like
you need to live the life of a
millennial entrepreneur right now build
for the future so for example right now
I've got a a like real estate like
portfolio with different properties Etc
in different countries but bro it's it's
stripping me dry every month bro I'm
paying money every month and sometimes
my wife she may not even understand why
are you doing that for why don't you
just save money right now I said I'm not
saving money right now what good is me
saving money right now when I can put
money in an investment that's going to
reap the rewards when I'm 32 33 34 and
then I've got you know four or five
properties to my name I've got this and
that I've got so many different things
you need to build your asset Library
build your asset library to the extent
where inshallah it comes to a point
where month on month you're making five
six seven eight thousand pounds and
don't feel entitled to anything no one
owes you a penny bro no one owes you
anything you have to go out and it's
it's it's it's basically doggy dog and
it and that's how you have to understand
it don't cut anyone up don't be unjust
in your business but go out there and
hustle as hard as you can and try and
try and find businesses that you think
work and make them better and scale them
up and that would be my advice to people
I've got so much more to say but I'm
obviously conscious of talking about
wallahi this is something that you have
to as a man focus on especially in the
demands of the West you can't be broke
man it's it's tough bro Allah bro it's
tough man and you know what bro
I'll just be real with you bro the
brothers that promote this broke
lifestyle you know it
it's it it's tough being broke and it's
tough
being wealthy you choose your tough and
a caveat a small disclaimer
by me saying this does not by any means
mean at all whatsoever in any way shape
or form the brothers who are poor who
don't have money right should not be
respected
wallahi bro you may have the Wali of
Allah you may have the friends of Allah
lived as a poor man and therefore we
should not glorify the life of an
entrepreneur and all these things bro we
shouldn't glorify and put people down
who are broke and who don't have money
because certain people they can't be
entrepreneurs and certain people are
comfortable in their jobs and that's
absolutely fine
and I generally find the people who are
telling people you need more money you
need more money eventually they're
trying to sell you a course now this is
generally kind of how it is that I've
seen it over the years and I'm seeing
the big Trend now as well and what I
would generally say is run your own rate
don't look left don't look right and
focus focus focus focus and give one
thing attention at a time don't try
doing too many things at the same time
as well and lastly remember that it's
not money that will make you happy
rather it's a contentment of the heart
the richness of the heart the closeness
and that intimate relationship with
Allah that is what will give you that
true contentment and richness of the
heart and you may be broken you may
struggle and you may have so many
problems your whole life but that may be
your way to Jannah the way to Jannah for
certain people like Usman
other people wolves to donate and was to
help and Muslims who are in position of
leadership should strive to be wealthy
that was their way to get to Paradise
your way may be the way of Abu Herrera
Salman al-si whoever who poor who don't
have that much money right your test is
your test don't worry if you can't if
you're trying to make hustle if you want
to make bread and you can't get to the
way you want to get to that's okay
that's fine and the people that brother
Allah he shame on you if you only spend
time with the elite and the wealthy
shame on you be with your brothers
especially if you're a daddy as
especially if you're giving dawah do not
be with the elite even religious Elite
don't always spend time with them be
with the common folk be with the people
on the ground be with the uncle in the
message have the humility throughout
your whole life because that is what
will keep you grounded and that is what
we all need in our lives as well
100 and people might be wondering what
am I looking down at for the last 10
minutes I was trying to find an eye in
the Quran I won I found one I wanted to
find the second one just to back up what
brother shahab is saying Allah
I'm going to read the translation here
but he says when one is touched with
hardship they cry out to us alone then
when we show when we shower our
blessings upon them they say I have been
granted all this only because of my
knowledge Allah says not at all it is no
more than a test Allah is saying Allah
is saying and he says this he's saying
it about both but specifically after he
says when we shower them with blessings
it's no more than a test meaning if you
are rich you're being tested and if you
are poor you're being tested same thing
Allah
he says when we basically when we when
we increase our servant in in risk and
Provisions he says my Lord has honored
me right
uh actually Allah says when we test our
servant and increase him in the risk he
says my Lord has honored me and when we
test him and we restrict the risk he
says my Lord has humiliated me but
what's the point that Allah in both
cases is testing you so we're gonna you
know live life with this test you know
are we going to work towards you know
living a uh a life where we can benefit
other people and and you know have money
and wealth and abundance which Muslims
should have insha Allah or are we going
to sit and be like you know I don't want
any of the Dunya so I'm just gonna sit
on my hands and wait till I Decay you
know
especially living in the west where you
have have so many opportunities and the
online world right now bro we should
take advantage of inshallah man but
exactly hello guys for having me man I I
really appreciate you guys having me on
here I feel like I've spoken way too
much man so forgive me go I don't I
don't normally do like this sort of
stuff so Charles it's all new to me as
well and uh shall love you we can maybe
do another one sometime soon but I
really appreciate the invitation and
thank you for honoring with Mama bless
you guys I love you for Allah
may Allah love you for loving us for our
sake Allah it was a pleasure having you
one you didn't talk too much don't worry
um you only talk too much about talking
too much so don't worry Have you uh you
know Elevate you thoughts
bro when we come to the UK inshallah in
a few months we gotta meet up and do
something 100
you go come check out some of
the 12s you guys
sure exactly Bless you keep you elevated
and progressing at the rate that you're
progressing at if not even faster and
allow you to reach more Hearts I mean
thank you
I mean and thank you all for watching
you all immensely one thing I want to
share before we end when you see someone
else is blessed with something it's not
from the Sunnah to say masha'allah it's
actually from the Sunnah they say
something like Allah
blessings in it for you so it's we see
and all I kept saying it throughout the
whole stream and I want to share it with
you guys because I feel like nobody
knows this unfortunately
don't say masha'allah unless you're
talking about yourself if Allah blesses
you with a good spouse say Masha Allah
towards yourself and when you see
someone you know Allah someone else say
Allah so Allah
he created two sides the movie go check
out the trailer it's on YouTube and
watch a movie inshallah whenever you get
the chance and with that being said
foreign